ya es una realidad Reino Unido y Francia
unificarán sus esfuerzos para intentar
frenar la migración de indocumentados
tras cerrar un acuerdo por 72,2 millones
de euros Francia ayudará a bloquear el
paso de personas por el Canal de la
Mancha una fuente de tensiones entre
ambas naciones en el pasado
tenemos que reducir significativamente
el número de personas que cruzan el
canal el Primer Ministro ha sido muy
claro Yo he sido absolutamente Clara en
cuanto a la migración ilegal
Especialmente con las cifras que hemos
visto recientemente es totalmente
inaceptable
con el dinero del acuerdo Se espera que
Francia aumente en un 40% sus patrullas
en las playas de la frontera entre 2022
y 2023 y que los mismos policías
británicos también las puedan vigilar
todo con la más alta tecnología como
drones perros detectores o helicópteros
para desmantelar las redes de
Contrabando y sobre todo para impedir
que la gente pase
hay varios elementos en el acuerdo y
creo que representan un paso positivo en
nuestra colaboración con los franceses
no se va a arreglar de la noche a la
mañana no es una bala de plata creo que
por primera vez tenemos ventajas tanto
para los franceses como para Reino Unido
más de 40.000 migrantes han cruzado la
frontera a través del Canal de la Mancha
en su mayoría albaneses iraníes y
afganos que huyen de conflictos internos
una cifra muy por encima de los cerca de
28.500 del 2021 algo que ha ejercido
presión sobre el nuevo gobierno de
richizunak no obstante tras políticas
como la devolución en caliente de
solicitantes de asilo a Ruanda muchas
organizaciones de defensa de derechos
humanos han criticado la política
migratoria de los conservadores en Reino
Unido